APPARENTLY IT'S NOT A BIG
NEWS STORY SOMEHOW.
UFOS TURN OUT TO BE REAL WE
ARE NOT KIDDING.
RECENTLY THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" REVEALED A SECRET
22-MILLION-DOLLAR PROGRAM
THAT INVESTIGATED THE UP
OUT OF SPACE.
THEY'RE NOT IDENTIFIED AND
THEY ARE FLYING AND THEY ARE
OBJECTS.
THEY FOUND MULTIPLE AIRCRAFT
ENCOUNTERS THEY COULD NOT
EXPLAIN AND STORING METAL
ALLOY.
LIZ MCCAIN WROTE ABOUT THIS
IN THE "NEW YORK TIMES" THAT
QUESTION AND ALSO WROTE A
BOOK CALLED UFO, GENERALS,
PILOTS AND GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS GO ON THE RECORD.
SHE SPENT YEARS
INVESTIGATING THE UFOs
WITH THE FORMER CHIEF OF
LESLIE JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR COME ON.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME,
TUCKER.
>> Tucker: THAT PIECE
VINDICATED A LOT OF WORK
THAT YOU HAVE BEEN DOING FOR
AN AWFUL LOT OF TIME.
LIKE YOU AND STARTED PAYING
ATTENTION.
IT SEEMS LIKE A HUGE STORY.
I KNOW IT'S VAST AND HARD TO
>> WELL, WE DO KNOW THAT
THERE ARE OBJECTS IN THE SKY
AND SOMETIMES IN THE WATER
SAY WE DON'T HAVE CREATING
THE KIND OF TECHNOLOGY OR
APPARENT TECHNOLOGY THAT'S
BEEN OBSERVED BY HIGH LEVEL
OFFICIALS FOR MANY, MANY
DECADES.
THE PENTAGON PROGRAM IS THE
MOST RECENT DISCOVERY BUT
THESE THINGS HAVE BEEN
STUDIED BY OTHER COUNTRIES
AND BY OUR COUNTRY FOR
YEARS.
>> Tucker: WHAT PERCENTAGE
OF THESE STUDS WERES ARE WE
>> MOST SIGHTINGS THAT
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT A VERY
MAYBE 5 TO 10% OF ALL THE
SIGHTINGS THAT ARE CALLED IN
ARE NOT EXPLAINABLE.
THE ONES OF INTEREST
MILITARY PILOTS, COMMERCIAL
PILOTS, TRAINED OBSERVERS,
MULTIPLE WITNESSES ONES
CAUGHT ON RADAR.
EVENTS THAT HAVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: SO I GUESS WHAT
BOTHERS ME MOST ABOUT THIS
STORY IS HOW CLEARLY PEOPLE
WHO SHOULD HAVE BEEN
FOLLOWING UP AND PAYING
ATTENTION HAVEN'T BEEN AND
THE CASE THAT STICKS WITH ME
NOVEMBER 7TH, 2006, CHICAGO
O'HARE AIRPORT, 4:15 IN THE
AFTERNOON GATE C-25 I
BELIEVE.
THE PILOT OF THE PLANE
WAITING TO DEPART TO
CHARLOTTE LOOKS UP AND THERE
IS A SAUCER HOVERING NOT
THAT FAR OVER THE PLANE.
PEOPLE IN THE TOWER SEE IT
OTHER PILOTS SEE IT DOZENS
OF PEOPLE SEE IT IT'S REAL
AND THE FAA REFUSES TO
INVESTIGATE.
HOW COULD THAT BE?
>> IT'S ABSOLUTELY SHOCKING
REASON PROBABLY IS THEY
CAN'T EXPLAIN THESE THINGS
AND THEY DON'T WANT TO DEAL
WITH THEM.
IT MIGHT FRIGHTEN PEOPLE.
THEY DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
INFORMATION.
THEY DON'T LIKE TO SAY WELL
THERE IS SOMETHING HOVERING
ABOVE AN AIRPORT WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT IT WAS.
BASICALLY THEY WILL COAL UP
WITH OTHER EXPLANATIONS FOR
IT SUCH AS IT WAS A WEATHER
PHENOMENON.
THAT'S WHAT THE FAA SAID
ABOUT O'HARE WHICH IS REALLY
KNOW THAT IT WASN'T WEATHER.
IT WAS METALLIC DISK SHAPED
OBJECT THAT HOVERED OVER A
TERMINAL GATE C 17 FOR FIVE
MINUTES AND SHOT STRAIGHT UP
CLOUD BANK AND ALL OF THE
SUDDEN IT JUST SHOT STRAIGHT
UP REALLY FAST THROUGH THE
CLOUD BANK AND CUT A HOLE IN
IT THERE WAS A COOKIE CUTTER
CLEAN HOLE IN THE CLOUDS
LOOK UP AND SEE THE BLUE ON
THE OTHER SIDE.
I HAVE BEEN TOLD WE DON'T
HAVE MACHINES IN THE SKY
THAT CAN DO THINGS LIKE
THAT.
>> Tucker: THIS IS NOT A
POTATO FIELD IN 1950S.
THIS IS CHICAGO O'HARE ONE
OF THE BUSIEST AIRPORTS IN
THE WORLD IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE DAY.
HOW COULD THAT BE?
>> IT'S VERY -- I APPRECIATE
HOW BAFFLED YOU ARE, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: I AM.
>> I'M BAFFLED, TOO.
YOU CAN IMAGINE THE
WITNESSES INVOLVED WITH
THIS, IT'S AN INSULT TO
THEM.
I MEAN, THERE ARE MANY
HIGH LEVEL PEOPLE IN THE AIR
FORCE, THE NAVY, THE OTHER
MILITARY COMMERCIAL PILOTS
WHO WERE JUST TOLD THAT
WE'RE NOT INTERESTED IN WHAT
THEY SAW.
PATRIOTIC PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: WHAT IT'S F. IT'S
THE CHINESE MILITARY?
I BELIEVE YOU BECAUSE YOU
ARE I THINK THE PREEMINENT
RESEARCHER ON THIS QUESTION
BUT IT BEGGARS BELIEF THAT
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT WOULD
JUST SORT OF LET IT GO.
I APPRECIATE.